where does Batman get those wonderful
toys is the Riddler using up his cell
phone minutes and does Batman have a
weird way of introducing himself to
criminals all that and more right here
in interviews describing his approach to
making Batman a more grounded character
on the big screen Matt Reeves may have
accidentally led fans to believe he was
issuing some of the more Fantastical
elements of the mythology in an effort
to stick with realism and I thought well
one place we haven't been is grounding
it the way that year one does
but within the film's first few scenes
we can see that isn't exactly the case
when Bruce arrives home from a night of
crime fighting he takes his contact
lenses out to reveal their actually
extremely tiny digital video cameras he
downloads data from them on a nightly
basis to revisit the details of his work
when updating his ongoing diary in case
files Bruce repurposes this Tech later
in the film when he needs Selena Kyle to
infiltrate 44 below at the Iceberg
Lounge through Selena's eyes Bruce is
able to see all the crooked cops and
politicians who regularly haunt this
secret mob hangout but when she and
Bruce argue after Selena runs off to
chase a different lead she angrily
prized the camera lens from her eye and
tosses it into a sink severing the
connection however much later in the
film when Selena needs a way to
communicate with Batman suddenly the
discarded lens makes a reappearance but
nothing gives the implication that
Selena saved it for later or that it's a
piece of tech you can just throw in a
purse and keep safe for future use
you have mysterious gadgetry the Batman
differs from Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
in a key way there is no lucious Fox to
outfit Bruce with all the wonderful toys
he utilizes in his war on crime what's
that
I'm on the Tumblr
or you wouldn't be interested in that
some elements are self-explanatory it's
clear from the design alone that Bruce
has made the bat suit himself and some
of the more rudimentary tools he deploys
are simple enough we don't need to know
where he got a grappling hook or a flare
but the aforementioned digital video
contacts the glider armor he uses to
escape the roof of the gcpd building
some of the computer tech and the bat
cave we have to essentially accept that
just like other adaptations all this
stuff comes from some unseen Wayne
Enterprises r d division even if that
answer is unsupported by the Casual way
Bruce insists he doesn't care about the
company or anything that goes along with
it
in one of the film's most tense moments
D.A Coulson crashes the mayor's funeral
with his mouth duct taped shut a
smartphone affixed to his hand and a
bomb strapped around his neck from the
moment Coulson arrives with the bomb the
smartphone is ringing
but a significant chunk of time passes
between Colson arriving and Batman
answering the phone day literally turns
to night are we to believe the Riddler
was sitting in his murder Lair mashing
redial for hours on end idly twirling
question marks into lattes to pass the
time the cops probably wanted to err on
the side of caution and worried
answering the phone would be the
Detonator trigger for setting it off so
it makes sense but somewhere around the
40 second ring was the Riddler maybe
second guessing this particular part of
his larger plan or did he foresee the
hours he would spend redialing the same
number over and over
one of the most interesting elements of
the bad man is how the bat suit looks
something like Bruce could have
conceivably made himself it feels less
like a giant mass of rubber molded into
fake musculature we've seen in past
films but there's one key element of the
plot that keeps recurring throughout and
makes it harder and harder to suspend
disbelief in multiple scenes Bruce is
shown walking around or riding his
motorcycle in street clothes carrying a
smallish backpack the suggestion is that
he changes into the Batman suit later
but save for one very quick series of
shots early in the film we never see the
process of what it's like to put on the
uniform it appears far too bulky and
elaborate to fit into that backpack even
though we're meant to surmise that each
time Bruce is ducking into Alleyways and
returning from the shadows and shrouded
in his war paint ready to fight the good
fight all that's missing is a Sailor
Moon transformation dance
thank you
I'm vengeance
this line in the Batman is first spoken
during the character's first on-screen
appearance during a fight with a gang of
face-painted thugs it returns as a
callback in several places in the film
when Selena first meets Batman the
penguin refers to him as Mr Vengeance
leading Selena to keep using the
nickname come on vengeance
but why did penguin ever call Batman Mr
Vengeance in the first place he wasn't
there when Bruce said that to the gang
did Batman ever say it to him it feels
like a fourth wall breaking moment to
something the audience is privy to but
not the individual character or and this
is somewhat weirder it implies that
Bruce says this so often to criminals he
beats up that it's a running joke in the
criminal community
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Batman are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]